all right you
ready hey Keith metro police come over
here hey metro police come over here all
right thanks buddy come on over here
appreciate your cooperation okay going
stand right here in front of the car yep
yep we going and put it down I know hang
on put put that down for a second all
right got
hooks you have anything on you sir
no okay yeah we'll get you a drink hang
on right just want to make sure you got
no weapons on you or anything
okay separate
the thank
you
put your palms together like you're
clapping I just want to make sure These
Cuffs can to be all right on you yep
[Music]
uh
good you have anything on you
sir phone and water phone and water
perfect we're going to put you in the
car I need I I need to drink some
water drink you just going for a walk or
what yeah
okay you do like a morning walk every
day
or okay we'll get you some water my man
got to get it now as soon as we get you
in the car we'll get we'll get you in
yeah one put in the car all right
appreciate it
sir all right let's walk over here sir
okay don't worry your water's going to
come
double walking all that yep that's good
you got legs I
don't hold on before
yep we got to put some leg Shackles on
you it's just part of our policy are you
wearing double pants sir you wearing
double pants or these are boxes all
right I'm G pull these all the way
up where go I'm down real
quick cool all right so going and have a
seat right in here I'm going to help you
out
yep just kind of put your butt up
against there kick that foot
up ready I'm a pro dude I got it you got
it all right he I'm a pro he said I'm a
pro all
right no we're
done I can do it my front is clear I'm
right
here okay
you have anything on you sir no all you
had was phone and uh water phone and
water we're going to put you in the car
I need I need I need a drink if you want
man I'm thirsty get a drink my man you
just going for a walk or what yeah
okay you do like a morning walk every
day
or okay we get you some water my man get
now yeah soon as we get you in the car
we'll get you we'll get all right
appreciate it
sir let walk over here sir okay going
wor your water's and
[Applause]
com you got legs I don't anybody have
legs yeah I got some yep hold on before
we put them
inep we got to put some leg Shack on
it's just part of our policy are you
wearing double pants sir you wearing
double pants the
Box
right have
right
there
got Pro you I'm a
[Applause]
pro anything else out here no we're done
custody
camera
y more that water
yep all right go swing your feet
out right over
here all right we're going to Walk This
Way
just biger steps I'll get you out of
those in a
second all right going to have you face
the car real quick you go yep separate
your feet for me lean up against the car
for
me
going to keep your phone up here with me
so it doesn't bounce
around all right sir go aad and have a
seat you need help or you got it all
right all right now you can sit as
sideway if that helps too I know those
things aren't the most comfortable
things ain't the fuzzy ones so I don't
know I'll be that in a sec yeah well all
right you got his paperwork or he
already knows Lieutenant Paige got it
yep no
problem so what they got you for
man biggest case in egas history oh yeah
yeah like
recent
September 7th
1996 oh
no
wow that's a long time that's a long
time away you know what I'm talking
about H you know what I'm talking about
yeah not a detective quite yet but
yeah it's a long time away man what was
that 20 something years no more than
that
yeah
should took him a while
huh I
worried well I mean that's what Court's
for
right oh so they uh raid your house and
stuff huh that was like mons ago
yeah walk around the corner just want
walk my
[Applause]
walk
wow they didn't make a scene like last
time oh they did oh they three
squat I'm in
my I hear a bunch of walkie-talkies in
the house behind me saw people over the
C
me and theat dude peeped over the gate
at the same
time in the
house my whole house this is Vegas
Metropolitan and we're very subtle then
huh do
that I was walking down the street dude
jumped
out apprehension team or
something